الآن بعد رحلة الرئيس بايدن إلى
مجموعة العشرين في الهند للقاء قادة عالميين
وزيارة إلى فيتنام لمناقشة
شراكة استراتيجية جديدة تحدث بايدن في
مؤتمر صحفي في فيتنام يوم الأحد
وانتهى الأمر بشكل مفاجئ قليلاً
ولم يكن تصادميًا على الإطلاق شكرًا
لكم جميعًا المؤتمر الصحفي لحساب الدفاع،
شكرًا للجميع،
شكرًا
جيدًا للموسيقى جانبًا، أريد إحضار إيلي
يوكلي، فهو محلل سياسي
للتشاور الصباحي حيث تحولنا في الحديث
قليلاً عن حملة إعادة انتخاب بايدن
في سباق 2024 بشكل عام، وهكذا في
حالة المؤتمر الصحفي
قال البيت الأبيض إنهم خططوا فقط لخمسة
أسئلة، وأدلى بايدن أيضًا بتعليق
قبل أن تبدو تلك اللقمة الصوتية وكأنها مزحة
تقول إنني لا أعرف شيئًا عنك ولكني
سأذهب إلى الفراش بشكل عام على الرغم من أن
نهاية هذا الكوى بهذه
الطريقة المحددة  مهم من الناحية السياسية، لقد
كانت موسيقى مزاجية مذهلة لأه
أخرجه، لست متأكدًا من مدى
تأثيرها عليه حقًا أه سياسيًا في هذه اللحظة،
لحظات مثل هذه لا تحظى بالكثير من
اللعب بين الشعب الأمريكي
بمفردها ولكن تبدو كثيرًا  تجتمع هذه الأشياء
معًا ومن الواضح أن الشعب الأمريكي
أكثر قلقًا بشأن
عمر بايدن ولياقته العقلية وقدرته على القيام
بعمله عما كان عليه قبل توليه
منصبه.